foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
it seems like
I don't know
Tucker Carlson's producers
we're listening to my monologue
yesterday
[Music]
just saying
if you're out there listening and you
work for Tucker Carlson's show Welcome
to the Tony Michaels podcast thanks for
watching thanks for listening I'm not
[ __ ] you I think someone is
listening
did you see the interview with Tulsi
gabbard last night
oh Tulsi
and George Santos
the most upstanding Republican at least
the [ __ ] is willing to admit
that he's a fraud and he's a liar
he's like yeah I told those lies but are
they really lies are they really
I mean I'm a republican isn't that a
requirement in the pre-requency to be a
total [ __ ] phony
I mean why is anyone so surprised
especially Tulsi gabbard you
you [ __ ] phony ass [ __ ]
concerned about George Soros
and his lies come on Tulsi give me a
[ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break
and there's one thing that George Santos
and and Tulsi gabbard have in common
they love Putin's money they love
Russian money oh they [ __ ] love it
why wouldn't they why wouldn't you do or
say anything absolutely anything if you
had an R next to your name
and the Russians were paying you maybe
that's what R means now in this country
maybe that's what it means Russian money
I don't know
everyone's wondering
how George Santos Was the janitor it God
knows where
made forty some thousand dollars and
then all of a sudden he donated
almost a million dollars to his own
campaign hmm
seems kind of funny didn't come from
money hmm
these Republicans always seem to come up
with cash out of nowhere
don't you think it's funny
but I told you yesterday I said
yesterday on the show and a lot of
people were in my YouTube comments
listeners here they were like Tony don't
encourage this
don't encourage him to stay in congress
and Republicans keep him in Congress
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh if we have Liars in
Congress it'll it'll set the bar are you
kidding me have you been paying the
[ __ ] attention
you're you're worried
you're worried about Republicans being
Liars in our Congress are you [ __ ]
serious
just because George Santos got caught
with his pants around his ankles
receiving Russian money and lying to to
become a member of Congress
doesn't mean the rest of the Republicans
aren't doing it every single moment that
they're on the house floor give me a
[ __ ] break with this don't encourage
the Liars to stay in congress
they're already there they're [ __ ]
there
there's 220 of them
they're [ __ ] Nazis what else would
they do besides lie and Gaslight America
give me a [ __ ] break this George
Santos story is only the cherry on top
of what is wrong with Republicans
and they should own it they should they
should be forced to deal with him being
a member of Congress last night watching
Tulsi gabbard talk about exactly what I
said yesterday yesterday I was probably
the first [ __ ] to say it because
I'm always the first [ __ ] to say
[ __ ] I said on this show yesterday go
rewind the tape that I can't wait for
George Santos to stand on the floor of
the [ __ ] house on our public record
and tell the same old Republican lies
out of his lying ass [ __ ] mouth
and Tulsi gabbard oh in true fashion
again Tucker Carlson's producers must
listen to this show welcome if you are
come every [ __ ] day
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours you [ __ ]
tune in
because last night Tulsi gabbard on
Tucker Carlson's show on fraud news said
exactly exactly what I said yesterday
that I want him to do and she said
that's what the Republicans don't want
him to do
I'm not I'm not gonna brush my shoulders
off that I'm one of the best pundits out
there but I am [ __ ] it I'm gonna say it
you want messaging you want narrative
come here if you wanna if you want to go
and listen to [ __ ] news and [ __ ]
media go somewhere else
I'm gonna give it to you straight I'm
gonna tell you what's important I'm
gonna tell you what the [ __ ] they're
paying attention to and what they're
trying to do with their politics and
their messaging and their narrative
and yesterday it just so happened that I
said on this show that the most
beautiful part that we're gonna hold
Republicans to account for the next two
years is George Santos and spouting off
Republican [ __ ] lies on the floor of
the house the same old [ __ ] because
Kevin McCarthy needs 218 and Tulsi
gabbard in true Fashion on Tucker
Carlson's show last night said that is
not what they want
so you decide I said yesterday that's
what we want and they said that's not
what they want so you you [ __ ] decide
so people in the comments even my
listeners criticizing me for [ __ ]
cheering on the Republicans putting
George Santos out front
get with the program start listening
start paying attention I'm telling you
politics is a [ __ ] we have to
put our fighting gloves on here
you think 2024 is gonna be a breeze hell
no
hell no they're gonna fight for every
inch of narrative that they can in this
country they're going to make up all
kinds of [ __ ] lies
all kinds of new [ __ ] and they're gonna
trudge out all the old garbage
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
sit back on the sidelines
are you gonna politicize this [ __ ] out
of everything they [ __ ] do because I
am that's what I'm gonna do every
[ __ ] move they make
yesterday me and Texas Paul talked about
the hunter Biden thing we should hold
100 by non-high we should make Hunter
Biden a [ __ ] hero that's right
over the next two years
we should love us some Hunter Biden
we're gonna find out how successful
Hunter Biden's businesses actually are
we're probably going to find out when
these tax returns drop for Trump that
Hunter Biden is wealthier than Trump
why do you think Don Jr is so pissed off
why do you think Don Jr is so [ __ ]
pissed off
well I mean his dad doesn't love him and
Hunter Biden's dad does that's one thing
but hunter Biden's got a shitload more
money than they get
because he's smarter at business who
cares if he does a little blow
I mean
just because you do a little bow doesn't
mean you're smarter business maybe Elon
should be cranking up the blow
maybe he may be making Better Business
decisions I don't know
possible
maybe that's why Don Jr does so much
blow I I can't figure it out I don't
know but back to George Santos Fox News
Tulsi gabbard and Tucker Carlson tonight
White Privilege tonight with Tucker
Carlson
guests starring Tulsi gabbard Jesus
Christ the [ __ ] is wrong with it she is
horrible by the way she is horrible as a
[ __ ] host
I don't know if you noticed that in
these clips of this interview but she is
[ __ ] god-awful as a host
why the [ __ ] did she gets Tucker Carlson
spot I have no idea
Jesus Christ
I mean Tucker's bad enough but God damn
she's dry she's not entertaining she's
not even a good guest when she's on
there they just [ __ ] love her because
she was a Democrat and now she's Putin's
puppet
[ __ ] break
Tulsi you're welcome to come on the show
so I can [ __ ] eat your lunch
you Tweed okay so let's get back to this
um this little interview with George
Santos and Tulsi it's not to knock too
much of her broadcasting skills that she
that doesn't exist
but old Tulsi digs into George just a
little bit makes him really [ __ ]
uncomfortable oh real [ __ ] he thought
he was gonna have it well on Fox news
but apparently someone had paid
attention to what the Democrats are how
we're going to use George Santos
I said yesterday we're going to use
George Santos you goddamn right
I'm gonna use him to create a national
narrative around him
oh he's the poster child for Republicans
he is what every Republican strives to
be even Marjorie Taylor green loves
George Santos Margaret Taylor Green's
like holy [ __ ] I I told lies about 911
false Flags Jewish space lasers but this
guy claimed he was Jewish and got away
with it and they voted him in
she can't believe it Marjorie Taylor
green can't believe what kind of lies
that George Santos got away with
I can't even I can't even imagine like
her little diary
Marjorie Taylor green dear diary
I wash my three toes this morning on my
left foot
but my right foot
I left it dirty gonna ride dirty today
also I can't believe the amount of lies
that George Santos got away with why am
I not allowed to get away with these
type of Lies I think I'll go tweet
something very vile and gross and she
did
oh she loves her some George Santos
Marjorie Taylor green oh my God I would
bet I would bet that Marjorie Taylor
green is gonna try to make a deal with
Kevin McCarthy that George Santos is the
third in charge in the Republican caucus
because he's so good at [ __ ] lying
why wouldn't he be actually you know
what you know what now that I'm thinking
about it now that I'm thinking about
this and we're having a little fun with
it why not make George Santos the
Speaker of the House for the Republican
caucus why not
he's he's obviously the greatest liar
that they have on their caucus
he's the most fantastic liar
and he's Jewish Jesus Christ are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
this is where they're at folks
everyone thinks everyone thinks that
Democrats are in disarray you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
okay the squad the squad voted against
some money and Appropriations [ __ ] them
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] AOC [ __ ] the squad that's
right I said it I said it
I said it [ __ ] them listen if if they're
not going to participate in democracy
and do what the caucus needs to do to
Snuff out these [ __ ] fascists then
whatever fine whatever you're gonna get
elected no matter what anyways so what
are we gonna do it just increases our
numbers by three or four
and Corey Bush the same way in Missouri
we need not pay them attention because
the more attention we pay them the more
they're able to tie and the media is
like oh look the Democrats in this array
they have four people
they have four Democrats that don't know
their head from their ass and how
politics are going to work and how to
win elections besides their own
that's what the media is going to run
with because that's the truth of the
matter the squad doesn't know how to win
elections but only their own and that's
the reason why they're voting the way
they're voting is so they can go out and
[ __ ] win primary challenges in their
District
so [ __ ] it you know need no pay
attention to that [ __ ]
what we need to pay attention to what we
need to pay attention to is point out
the [ __ ] frauds and the Liars the
cheaters the fascist and the Republican
caucus if you think if you think that
the squad voting against Appropriations
is way is is more dangerous than a bunch
of fascists wanting authoritarianism and
wanting to make Donald Trump the
dictator and king of this country you're
a stupid [ __ ]
I mean two things can be right at the
same time AOC in the squad can be
worthless as [ __ ] when it comes to
Appropriations the vote on
Appropriations as well as the Republican
caucus actually being the danger to our
democracy okay
two things can be the same at the same
they can both be wrong at the same time
at the right time wrong time who gives a
[ __ ]
but people telling me in the comments
that I should not encourage Liars
staying in Congress Jesus Christ what
what [ __ ] Republican isn't a goddamn
Absolute Total liar at this point a
fraud you really think Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan isn't a fraud
you think Matt gatz isn't a liar and a
total fraud what about Lauren bobert
by the way I forgot to bring that up
yesterday with Texas Paul did you hear
she lost her [ __ ] restaurant because
she's a worthless piece of [ __ ] and she
makes way more [ __ ] money grifting
than she does serving up diarrhea
Burgers down in her [ __ ] food joint
did you hear they closed a restaurant
and in its place is gonna be a Mexican
restaurant oh my God you can't get any
more [ __ ] poetic than that
not you can't you just can't
the romance of that story
Lauren bobert losing a restaurant and a
Mexican a Mexican dining restaurant
opening up in its place is [ __ ]
beautiful
can't make this [ __ ] up I forgot to
bring that up yesterday but bobert's a
total [ __ ] fraud
Kevin McCarthy you think he's not a
[ __ ] fraud come on
after 9 11 he's like oh the president of
the United States is responsible and now
he's a [ __ ] boot licker gonna open up
committees to investigate how the
insurrectionists who have been charged
with seditious conspiracy and convicted
in some cases how they were treated as
political prisoners get the [ __ ] out of
here all at the same breath saying that
it was antifa it wasn't Trump supporters
which is it you dumb [ __ ] are
they political prisoners are they antifa
which is it and you think you think the
danger is George Santos a [ __ ]
freshman congressman from New York's
third going on the floor and lying
saying the old old every old Republican
lie about inflation and gas prices milk
prices
Health Care the same old [ __ ] lies
about Ukraine and the Border come on
immigration the list goes on and on and
on and you think he's the threat no
he's their badge of honor
and we should pin it to him and make him
[ __ ] own it
that [ __ ] shouldn't resign he
should stay fast and keep lying he's a
republican why not
so all of you out there who think that
it's a bad idea for Republicans to say
the quiet part out loud you are full
yourself and you are fooling only you
I'm telling you we have to create
messaging in a narrative that is
National across the entire country we
have to convince people we have to
convince people who are enamored by
delusion
they're they're they're past bias
and their confirmation bias of
affiliation of the Republican party we
have to convince them that it is a
absolute [ __ ] garbage heap and it's
not going to be easy it won't
it's gonna take a lot of people yelling
and screaming every [ __ ] day
to create a narrative
Republicans served us so much on a
platter in 2022.
they made so many key mistakes that they
may not make for 2024.
they way overstepped Roe v Wade and as
soon as Roe v Wade was overturned or
that the notion of it being overturned
they were salivating salivating at the
idea to take away women's rights in this
country
they way overstepped
do you think we'll be able to carry that
into 2024 that may be [ __ ] difficult
folks
it's it may be really [ __ ] difficult
to win elections off that
hell we even had Blake Masters that
[ __ ] fascist piece of [ __ ] America
First Nazi down in Arizona changing his
goddamn campaign website when he
realized they way overstepped
they'll lie about anything
anything they don't give a [ __ ] if it
would benefit them and their power
they'd be for Universal Health Care
tomorrow okay
if they thought their base would buy
into that [ __ ]
and and they could grift off their base
they would do it in a heartbeat you
watch Trump do it in 2016.
you watched him do it
what makes you believe that they won't
say absolutely [ __ ] anything they
have to to [ __ ] win
anything
Jesus Christ Have you listened to some
of this Q Anon stuff
I mean not not the not the the top foam
[ __ ] right
not the top the foam and the beer I'm
talking about deep down inside the beer
the glass of beer holy [ __ ]
it's Stout as [ __ ]
it's some crazy ass [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
cult
and I'm gonna show you a video today of
someone who is frustrated and and
frustrated with the cult
it's it's fantastic
and and we with the national narrative
have done this to them
I know it's I know it seems like well
can you really weaponize messaging and
narrative yes absolutely how do you
think we won 2022 and we won even though
they got the House of Representatives
they did that with gerrymandering
there's nothing we could do with
messaging our narrative to change the
sentence census that they rigged
to make sure they could gerrymander
their way back into power
there's nothing we could do about that
we can do something about that in the
future make sure whoever the [ __ ] is in
charge of the next census isn't a
goddamn lunatic
use your head
use your brains use your thoughts more
importantly use your voice
because it's not just about voting at
The Ballot Box I mean we're gonna get
there we got there in 2022 where you
needed to vote
you had to vote in primaries to make
sure we had good candidates that could
win then you had to get to the
[ __ ] polls to make sure these
[ __ ] did not take control of
everything and anywhere and ever in in
all of it and you did that we [ __ ]
did it
the key races that were so important
were the governor's races the next
important
was Secretary of States and those states
that were most important Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin and Arizona
now would we have liked to have Georgia
in Florida of course
would we have liked to have Texas of
course we would but we didn't get there
that's why I'm telling you the next two
years we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to really form our national
narrative
break this affiliation cycle
to make sure that people who just go
vote Republican because there's a
[ __ ] Russian R next to their name
like George Santos
that's how he won folks that's how he
[ __ ] won George Santos didn't win on
his lies George Santos won because
there's an R next to his name
it's what it is affiliation
you need to get used to it
and the sooner the sooner that
protemocracy people understand exactly
why people vote in this country
and why they vote the way they vote I
should say
the easier it's gonna be for us to make
sure that we save our democracy from
these [ __ ] boxes
like George Santos
it's simple it really is simple
but it's hard work
and George Santos won that seat folks he
won that election it's certified there
ain't a goddamn thing that we can do to
stop him from [ __ ] being from from
being sworn in and he'd take the oath on
January 3rd
and Kevin McCarthy needs his vote
so let's make them own it that's all I'm
saying [ __ ] them
let's not them let's not let them run
around
ignoring the fact that George Santos is
a good Republican because he lies
let's make them [ __ ] wear that badge
that's wine last night after I said in
the morning
that that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] is gonna
go to the floor of the house and tell
the same old Republican lies
and no one's gonna believe that [ __ ] not
even Republicans that's what they're
terrified of
Kevin McCarthy wants to get his vote and
wants him out they do not want George
Santos standing on the floor of the
house telling their same old lies I do
I do
and I do for the narrative and messaging
because we're gonna win
we are going to win in 24.
and we have to keep pushing the needle
and the only way to push the needle
is to fight back against their fascist
lies
and what better way than the pointing
out to everyone in this country
that the biggest [ __ ] liar the
biggest [ __ ] fraud that there is is
saying the same old [ __ ] that every
other Republican is trying to sell you
hmm
we'll get at least at least four to six
months good months out of this
[ __ ]
at least because this sumbitch
he loves a [ __ ] camera this is George
Santos boy he loves the camera and he
loves the microphone and I'm in love
with that
he's not going to slink away
motherfucker's gonna get in front of
cameras and say all kinds of [ __ ]
make them own it that's our goal and our
goal is to win for democracy and one way
you can do that is to come here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe while you're here on the
YouTube channel you're not going to want
to miss a thing
I do want to give you some news though
uh you know we took a Christmas break so
we're going to take a break for New
Year's next Monday on the second
we're gonna have another day off
it'll be our last day off for a long
time folks
wow we gotta take a break every once in
a while I think I added up this morning
and I think
I took five days five days off for our
regular programming schedule
for last for this year for 2022. now In
fairness we weren't doing
shows five days a week in January and
part of February
but we started up pretty darn quick in
2022 and I only missed five
five it's how many so I missed one
week's worth of shows
and you guys have been here every single
week every single show you're the best
audience in the world it's growing and
growing and growing that's why that's
why I think someone's listening out
there if you're listening and you're
producing right wing shows welcome
welcome to the place where we form the
national narrative
and the messaging to kick your fascist
right-wing ass
got it come here listen and then go do
your little show you're gonna need it
that's how offense works
that's how offense works folks
so come listen and and also follow us on
Twitter at Tony michaelspot we're gonna
have a bone end of the week this week
now I'm Gabe Sanchez is still feeling a
little under the weather
so I don't know if you'll he'll join us
today or not
um he's still nursing
um his sickness and he's so he's taking
an extended break for Christmas so and
maybe we'll have Gabe Sanchez today
maybe we'll we'll figure that out
through the show but I got some Great
Clips to show you of this Tulsi George
Santos interview I'm gonna go through it
because folks I'm telling you this is a
wedge that we can draw
this is going to be a huge wedge for the
Congress we have to draw a wedge for the
presidential election and we have to
draw a wedge for the Congress
if you want to win it back from these
Republicans we have to show the entire
country just how inept
an unqualifying they are to hold the
House of Representatives so don't go
anywhere we're going to do that as soon
as we come right back right after this
break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
couple things I forgot to mention in the
monologue I don't know if you were
paying attention but the transcripts in
case the testimony I started dropping
yesterday and apparently
Scott Mark Meadows burning top secret
documents
almost a dozen times in his fireplace in
the White House what in the [ __ ] these
people watch way too many [ __ ] movies
do you agree with me way too many
[ __ ] movies where they think they
could just fire up the old fireplace and
throw the [ __ ] pictures in and throw
the top secret documents in her you
I'm sorry I'm sorry that I'm laughing
this is [ __ ] they are such they are
such [ __ ] they've lost their way they
really have lost their way that achieve
a staff for the United States president
thinks that he can just fire up the old
fireplace in his office and just start
burning top secret documents are you
[ __ ] kidding me
they watch way too much TV
and they got way too much time on their
hands they weren't busy enough running
the country apparently Jesus Christ and
then we find out that [ __ ] members of
Congress were toting over documents to
give to Donald Trump hey there was a guy
on YouTube his name's Tony Michaels and
he was saying that the reason why
Merrick Garland
put the documents case and the January
6th case in charge of in the charge of
Jack Smith is because they're related
hmm hmm
of course they are of course they're
related case if you think Donald Trump's
treason only extends to January 6 and
it's a different type of treason
for the documents case and him stealing
documents and destroying documents and
Mark mendels destroying documents get
the [ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
you [ __ ] you you you are not paying
attention okay
and Mark Meadows has flipped if you want
to know the truth I've got this question
I've had some people text me I've had
people call and ask me do you think Mark
Meadows flipped yes Mark Meadows has
flipped 100 percent he flipped for the
doj he did not for the select committee
you want to know the reason why
he doesn't want Maga to know that he
flipped
he doesn't want the Trump supporters to
know that he is flipped
he's terrified of him terrified
absolutely [ __ ] terrified
and the reason why is because the other
thing we found out about the [ __ ]
Cassie Hutch's testimony is he son of a
[ __ ] were running around talking
about Q Anon Oath Keepers and proud boys
in the White House and planning
I wonder I wonder if we could um I
wonder if we could subpoena if the doj's
gonna subpoena
Genie Thomas
the head q and on our conspiracy
theorist that was texting Mark Meadows
listen if you [ __ ] don't think that
all this is tied together
you are bonehead every single bit of
this treason is all tied together and
it's all tied to his tiny little [ __ ]
ego that little [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
I'm talking about Grandpa poopy pants
now the Cheeto dust chewing on her
they were literally trying to trying to
use Q Anon conspiracy theories to
overthrow your vote and overturn our
democracy so that Donald Trump didn't
have to appear to be a loser
at tiny hand little [ __ ] lunatic
[ __ ] him and [ __ ] anyone who supports or
helped him [ __ ] you and you know what
there's going to be a long off-ramp here
but we shouldn't just let these people
off the ramp quickly
I'm telling you for 2024 we can't let
these people all of a sudden be our
allies
all of a sudden because they leave Trump
they're gonna have to repent in public
that is what they're going to have to do
they can't just go oh well I I never
wrote well I mean I mean I used to I
mean I I deleted all that cute on stuff
off my Facebook
nope sorry
nope
say it out loud say it say it you were
lying
you were duped
and you were full of [ __ ] all of it the
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] in caboodle
it was a cult admit it out loud then
we'll let you off the ramp come on
it's what we got to do
it's gonna be it's gonna be imperative
for our national healing for these
people to take responsibility and I'm
not just talking about the people held
responsible for the ones that were
planning the Insurrection and the ones
that tried to carry out the violent
Insurrection at the Capitol
I'm talking about the people who were
encouraging and still encouraging the
[ __ ]
they have to be they have to hold
themselves accountable in public hold
themselves accountable not us I mean you
have the justice department is going to
do their job for the criminals that plan
this [ __ ] they're doing their job for
the criminals that acted out the violent
insurrection
The Oath Keepers trials coming up
they've already they've already
convicted the oath the oak excuse me the
proud boys Trials come out they're
already convicted I get these two
confused they already got the Oath
Keepers convicted
and hundreds hundreds
of the absolute the absolute megalodites
that showed up
to commit violence take their country
back
and wanted to hang Mike Pence you
remember all this
went over it but the January 6th select
committee but as this testimony drops
just remember one thing
remember one thing that's most important
that the Department of Justice and Jack
Smith is looking at these transcripts
to see if it coincides with the
testimony that they're getting
okay
man it's what is most important here
that
Jack Smith
is absolutely
going to sniff out
any [ __ ] that had anything to do
with planning and trying to carry out
January 6. he's probably gonna overturn
rocks for two goddamn years
and it's not going to be pretty for
Trump and his allies
and it's going to be juicy for us but we
have to use it in the correct way
yes we have to politicize it in the
correct way to form a national narrative
and messaging it's working
it's working you remember I don't know
when the January 6th select committee
was formed right
all over the Internet Tic Tac Instagram
Twitter
Facebook oh if if he if he's indicted
there'll be a civil war if he's indicted
we'll go to war people
it's like there was 15
000 Yosemite Sams on every single social
media site
and hundreds of Yosemite Sams in your
[ __ ] threat
and then the January 6th select
committee refers criminal charges to the
Department of Justice
and we got crickets
hmm
hmm
you don't you don't think there's
something funny about that
it's because they're full of [ __ ]
this this fraud that he has wide base
support in this country is a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he does not have white base support
again it's support by affiliation yes he
has his cult I'm not gonna deny that
these these [ __ ] cult members that
he's grifting off of that he's taken
advantage of
oh my God
now they're peeling off little by little
that's why he has to come up with genius
ideas like the Trump trading cards as a
money laundering scheme to get his money
out of his gifting account or his his
political grifting account into his
personal drifting account you gotta
remember that I think that's what's
going on there
he's just trying to wash that money that
he's putting into his own pocket because
he can't you know there's certain things
with his political donations that he can
and can't do I mean you know he can do
just about anything he wants but not
everything he wants like I don't know
get on his plane with banks full of cash
and go hide under Putin's desk
I don't know we'll find out if he flees
the country
some people say that I don't think he
actually will
not only will
anyways
Jack Smith is going to absolutely
destroy Donald Trump and his allies
and Mark Meadows yes Mark benos has
flipped
if you go and you look at the criminal
charges that Congress referred that have
to do with their their investigation
right because that's typically you know
that was sort of the the criticism
from some of the legal analysts if you
want to call it that
from the criminal referral of Donald the
criminal referrals multiple referrals of
Donald Trump
is that normally when Congress refers
crimes it's crimes against them right
which technically insurrection
and trying to obstruct their official
proceeding against crimes against them
so it is against them
but if you go back and you look at the
charges of contempt where Bannon Peter
Navarro Mark Meadows several others were
not participating in their lawful
subpoenas
and you have Navarro and Bannon they
were charged abandon's even been found
guilty he's an appeals process to make
sure his ass doesn't go to prison
for a couple months
here's the thing Mark Meadows
that contempt
referral to the doj what happened to
that hmm why why is it
that Mark Meadows
is not being charged with contempt
from the referral from Congress from the
Department of Justice you gotta remember
Congress
is in one branch of government and the
Department of Justice is in another
branch of government
and because they're two separate
branches they don't always communicate
with each other the best that's why
Benny Thompson
and mayor Garland weren't getting along
when it comes to the January 6
investigations evidence given to the
Department of Justice
this is a thing that happens inside
co-equal branches of government and it's
designed that way
to be quite honest it is actually
designed that way for them not
to
to coordinate too closely
we do not want a trust me we do not want
our branches of government to coordinate
too closely
that would subvert the separation of
powers okay you do not want that exactly
so the fight between Benny Thompson and
mayor Garland
is nothing more than to protect our
constitution
in our democracy if you just want to get
down to the bare all bones of it
but the reason why Mark Meadows
has not that referral from the January 6
elect committee from the Congress to the
Department of Justice it seems like it's
been dropped is because the Department
of Justice knows
that Mark Meadows is not in contempt
what do I mean by that he's flipped for
the Department of Justice
that's right I believe that that's why
Mark Meadows that contempt referral from
Congress has not been acted on by the
Department of Justice
because the Department of Justice knows
Mark Meadows is not
in contempt with them
he may have been in contempt with
Congress but what do they give a [ __ ]
I mean what what does the doj give a
[ __ ]
think about it for a second if the doj
knows that Mark Meadows
is giving them the information that they
need for their investigation
but he didn't exactly give the
information that Congress and the select
committee exactly wanted
they don't give a [ __ ]
so think about it for a second and this
is this has to terrify has to terrify
Grandpa poopy pants
the Cheeto nuts q and r
because he doesn't know if Mark Meadows
is probably on his side and flipped or
not
and I think this is part of Mark
Meadow's plan because out of all these
buffoons that thought that they could
overthrow our government
Mark Meadows being the chief of staff
and and the main point of communication
for planning for Donald Trump planning
his his overthrow of our Constitution
and installing himself as the dictator
of the United States
Mark Meadows has a shitload of
information
and for Donald Trump not to know because
that's generally what happens too with
the Department of Justice
is they generally trying to make it to
where
folks don't know
if a person is flipping or not I don't
know if you you remember the cash Patel
Saga
of the documents case that's gone by the
wayside too hasn't it we haven't heard
much from cash lately
after he went and testified to a grand
jury in the Department of Justice
about the documents
that Grandpa Poopypants stole that cash
Patel claims he used some kind of magic
power to declassify these things
and it's now known that no that is not
how it works number one and he didn't
just declassify any of this [ __ ] it's
all classified and they aren't his
documents he's stealing them to hide
evidence about January 6 and other
crimes that he made committed
like I don't know colluding with Russia
in 2016. hmm or covering up [ __ ] about
his Ukraine impeachment hmm
I wonder if that's what he's doing
of course that's what he's doing
of course he's trying to cover his ass
with with these documents
of his coup attempt from January 6th
where members of Congress
were actively helping him plan it
by giving him classified documents from
the intelligence committee you think he
was thumbing through and knew what he
wanted knew what he needed to cover it
he's a [ __ ] buffoon he had no [ __ ]
clue what he needed and what classified
documents he needed to cover this up why
do you think he installed cash would
tell over a DOD
why do you think members of Congress
like Jim Jordan and others were bringing
him class and and [ __ ] Devin Nunes
were bringing him classified documents
he doesn't know exactly what he needs to
have he had he was having his fascist
Maga lieutenants do it for him
come on
[ __ ] your head out of your ass and
realize that absolutely that document's
case is the January 6 case folks
the document's case is just how
[ __ ] got caught
in the planning of covering up his
attempt
of a coup
it's same [ __ ] documents case is the
January 6th case same [ __ ]
same
[ __ ]
same exact one now
I forgot to mention that
in the monologue so I figured I'd bring
it up for a couple minutes here in the
show
um let's go to the Tulsi gabbard
and George Santos interview actually you
know what you know what let's let's
leave that for a minute
I don't want to quite get there yet
since we're on the Q a non Trump
supporter these [ __ ] weirdos I gotta
show you a video that Patriot takes uh
found and posted now this I don't know
what this is like this is some kind of I
don't know if it's like a zoom meeting
with these q and I don't know this is a
cult Seance a digital virtual cult
Seance I have no [ __ ] clue because
this person you know she's got you know
Christmas decorations but it looks kind
of like a seance to me here's the um
here's the tweet that Patriot takes put
out it says Q Anon I'm hearing quits
and melt down against Q Army after going
six years without being acknowledged by
Q Steve Bannon or Laura Logan I you know
Laura Laura Laura I don't know I think
it's Laura maybe it's Laura Laura Logan
tweeted at me once because I called Andy
Noah Nazi because he is
[Music]
she tweeted at me one time I had no idea
who this was
I had no clue who Laura Logan was now in
in recent years she's become just an
absolute q and on lunatic and delusional
spreading lies and propaganda for Andy
no all over the internet I don't know
what Andy what she owes Andy no but God
damn it's pathetic now she used to be
our actual reporter and she had an
incident overseas now where she was she
was raped multiple times and this lady
brings this up
that's the only reason why I bring it up
because this lady brings it up because
there's a lot of [ __ ] in this clip that
I have no [ __ ] clue what this lady is
saying I am not a goddamn clue what
she's talking about she's talking in in
some kind of cult language using all
kinds of Q Anon buzzwords and all right
phrases I am no [ __ ] clue
what she's talking about
but it's delicious
because she's totally you can tell on
the clip she's totally turning on Q and
Q Anon and not only the the belief
system but the leaders which is that
again
this is the main thing that we have to
do this lady needs to get on the off
ramp of Q Anon but she's gotta go and
speak against how delusional she was and
how crazy it was and how much of a cult
it was before we let her off the op ramp
but in this clip you're gonna see some
crazy [ __ ] roll the camera
um it is [ __ ] weirdness weird a weird
ass exchange here that she's having
um now I believe she's just doing some
kind of Zoom live thing kind of like I
do here where there's a chat and she's
talking to the chat
like people are chatting at her
but she keeps talking about orbs and
other [ __ ] I have no idea what the hell
that is so when she starts saying orbs
and stuff don't ask me maybe someone in
the in the comments knows I have no idea
what that means in Q Anon language but
let's give this a quick listen here roll
the camera there are a lot of orbs here
right now but that's okay because
nothing you say or do right now Q is
gonna stop me
[ __ ] off all of you seriously I quit so
I don't know who which who she's talking
to right
like I don't know what the orbs thing is
does anyone know what the orbs thing is
because there's like and you know um
when you have a window that's open in
your house and you see all the dust
particles right you're like Jesus Christ
is Dusty in here but you don't normally
see them unless the light shining
through them right
and it feels like to me in the in the
video clip and I'm gonna get to the
where she quit skew part but see the see
the snowflakes
she starts talking in these these the it
looks like dust particles are falling in
front of the camera I don't know if
that's what she's talking about
um if that's the orbs or not
I guess maybe but I mean and and I don't
know if there's like someone standing
behind the desk like throwing like bits
of Styrofoam uh someone's saying yes it
is
it's the um
that's what she's saying the orbs what
the [ __ ] does that mean
what the [ __ ] does that mean
so there there is there is obviously
someone standing behind the the camera
throwing [ __ ] in the air
for her to respond to this orbs thing or
is it like
are they putting it on the [ __ ]
are they putting it on the the like a
filter like a snow filter
on your Instagram or something I [ __ ] I
don't know I couldn't figure that out I
had no idea what the [ __ ] that means
Gary thinks it's a filter
he says filter
yeah I don't know if it's a filter I
have no idea
MJ says orbs I can't I can't figure it
out I can't figure it out but I I think
someone I mean this is what I want to
imagine
that her [ __ ] husband
is standing behind the [ __ ] the
camera
and he's got bits of Styrofoam in his
hand right you know you know when you
get a when you get something new
something new for Christmas and it's got
styrofoam things you grind it down to
Define little
little styrofoam pieces they're all over
the [ __ ] floor you know what I mean
when you get it out of the box and
you're trying to put something together
[ __ ] the [ __ ] styrofoam's there
when you can't even hardly sweep the
[ __ ] up you know what I'm talking about
that kind of [ __ ]
someone's standing there with a handful
of it and they're just they're just
blowing it off their hand into her hair
or some [ __ ]
he just you see the [ __ ] on the camera
because the first thing I thought when
she was yelling at orbs I thought she
was yelling at the the people in the
chat and they were called orbs like the
people in the chat were orbs
you know like we have great mods here
right the moderators so maybe I thought
it meant orbiters you know I don't know
[ __ ] I don't know anything I I mean
I don't know everything about this Q
Anon [ __ ] how could you pie if you did
know you'd be in so deep you might be a
cult member
so let's watch it again and see what you
think
of all of you seriously I quit
I quit q and Q are me and the reason why
I quit is because on December 19th
2022 Q refused to acknowledge my Q Plus
3730 and I okay
so she's she's really upset at Q himself
I don't know what the 37 30 is I have no
idea
does anyone know what the [ __ ] that is
I refuse to accept my 37 I think I think
she wants attention
well she's getting attention here today
oh my God this is the same lady right
that you see in like the grocery store
losing her mind in line but Karen
because she's got a coupon that expired
yesterday but she wants them to honor
the coupon
and she's gonna hold up the whole
[ __ ] line the whole [ __ ] store
she's gonna make them call the cops on
her to drag her out of the store because
she won't she wants her 50 cents off her
pill Pillsbury crescent rolls you know
what I'm talking about same [ __ ]
here
whoosh
whoosh you couldn't get more
stereotypical
than this white Karen good Lord okay
let's let's keep with the crazy here
because it it gets better I've been
doing it for six years
next year that means I have to wait for
another year look at all these orbs see
that see the dust particles are the the
styrofoam whatever the [ __ ] it is if
it's a filter
and I don't know but they come up on the
screen and say look at all the orbs look
at all the orbs what the [ __ ]
should we get orbs here
I don't know should we have an orb
filter
you're saying maybe I'm behind on the
times
oh it must be delightful to be this
[ __ ] crazy you know what I mean if
you if you absolutely wanted to be a
happy person you would be this kind of
out of your mind
I mean how you'd have to be right
why else would you get this [ __ ] nuts
nuttier than a goddamn squirrel turd
other than to you know they say
happiness is bliss so
Jesus let's continue I'm telling you it
gets better and better and better here
she gets more and more pissed off at the
orbs and a cue and at other people let's
listen you guys get lost I'm not coming
back no matter what you do right here
with these orbs just so you know no
matter what happens from here on NQ I'm
not coming back you're on your own and
in fact I'm taking down
the ET Transmissions [ __ ] you [ __ ] all
of you on the
ET Transmissions
okay well there's a new thing we got to
break down that I have no [ __ ] clue
what she's talking about
this this is how delusional these people
are
this is how deep in this [ __ ] cult
Rabbit Hole these stupid bastards are
and you're standing around wondering why
they're voting the way they're voting
and I don't know some someone pointed
out this morning that she may sound
Canadian which she may be apparently
there's a big huge cult following for Q
Anon in Canada too
you know they're lurching towards the
right wing I mean q Anon is trying to
Lurch every single country towards the
right wing which if you're not if you're
not following anything you're not you're
not following the Q is Russian
propaganda
that's what it is it's Russian narrative
pushing these people down this Rabbit
Hole of [ __ ] crazy but what the hell
isn't is she talking about
extraterrestrial Transmissions that's
what E.T means to me
is that what she's saying
is this the Jewish space laser [ __ ] what
in the actual [ __ ]
like I you know I I have family members
that have fallen to cue some of them
know it some of them don't know it you
know what I mean like they believe a ton
of [ __ ] on Facebook that is Q Anon they
just don't know it's queuing on and when
you're like you know that's q and I'm
like oh I I'm not queuing man that
shit's crazy like this lady she's crazy
but they believe all kinds of crazy ass
[ __ ]
that this lady believes they're just not
that deep in the rabbit hole but what in
the is she talking about Transmissions
from Aliens is that what she's [ __ ]
talking about
what in the [ __ ] uh someone says she is
Canadian
yeah I I mean I I don't know I don't I
don't know who this lady is the only
reason why I think this video is
significant isn't about her
it's not about her it's about her
delusion okay that is the most important
part and the reason why I think this is
so important to show you this
because you know that I have intention
here and my intention is for you to
politicize this stuff right now the most
important thing you can do is if you're
close to someone that believes this Q
Anon [ __ ] you slipped in this [ __ ]
video I'm telling you
and show them how [ __ ] crazy they
look
right
they're worried about [ __ ] drag shows
entertainment menus
grooming children and pushing our
society
into a complete [ __ ] tailspin look at
this lady
I mean her delusion is so crazy that her
craziness is leaking out when she's
turning on them
let's continue I'm telling you it gets
better as it goes it's it's crazy I I
want to point out some Elizabeth says on
YouTube Flynn and I think she's saying
Mike Flynn which I believe that's true
is Q now Mike Flynn has a lot to do with
the Q narrative in this country q a
we've had uh um we've had Jim stewartson
on talking about that he's got a film
about it and Jim Jim is over on Mastodon
um he does post a lot of mastan I don't
get on Master not a lot I tried to but
there's way too many [ __ ] social
medias for me to keep track of but Jim
is over on Mastodon if you want to go
over there and follow him if you can't
find him on Mastodon just go to my
account on Masson it's just at the Tony
Michaels and I got the link on in at the
Tony michaels.com and you can go and you
can go to my followers and and find Jim
probably and go follow Jim we've had him
on the show before
um and he he believes and he's got a lot
of
um work that he's done to prove that
Mike Flynn is q
but this [ __ ] gets crazier so hang on
hang on hang on to your your seat here
let's let's continue on this planet all
right I tried to give the E.T
Transmissions to Lara Logan I tried to
give him to Steve Bennett Lira Logan
Laura Logan I got gang raped a whole
bunch of times therefore I'm in I'm a
legit journalist [ __ ] Laura Logan
didn't I tell you that she brings it up
so she's giving
um
extraterrestrial transmissions and she
says from another planet
right
and so I'm I'm guessing these are
extraterrestrials Transmissions that
she's received
um this is a whole level of [ __ ]
crazy right
who else who else wants to figure out
what she's using to pick up these
transmissions and send her all kinds of
subliminal messages
ah
the orb talk the E.T Transmissions holy
actual [ __ ] if you're not aware that
this is a cult yet God damn
I don't know if you've done any kind of
research or just watch one documentary
on a cult but this is crazy ass [ __ ]
it's crazy ass [ __ ]
and they believe it Hook Line singer
Steve Stevie you son of a [ __ ]
Steve on YouTube says is that Carrie
Lake's mom I it could be you know what I
mean I mean I'm not gonna it may be
Carrie Lake without the filter
you know our soft filter it may be
Carrie Lake without the filter this is
what happens to you you know how how
quick you age
uh when you believe Q Anon so it may be
Carrie like it may be your mom hell it
might be his sister I don't know maybe a
cousin maybe a Canadian cousin [ __ ] I
don't know
whoosh okay let's let's keep going I'm
telling you this is important you're
thinking why the [ __ ] is he showing us
this crazy lady on some kind of [ __ ]
Zoom call
because I'm telling you this is this
this is where
this is where a small percentage of the
country right it's a small percentage
but it's a large number of people are at
this is why they they give him ninety
dollars or a hundred bucks for trading
cards that are just a fraud this is why
they continue to mortgage their house to
support Donald Trump
this is why right here you're watching
it now she's you know frustrated because
of Laura Logan
didn't take her extraterrestrial
Transmissions or whatever the [ __ ] she's
yapping about but here's the thing she
actually says she says the reason why
Laura Logan says that she's a legitimate
reporters because she was gang-ranked
which
Laura Logan was
sexually assaulted several times
apparently in in in gang rapes overseas
while she was reporting
but she used to be an action reporter
she is not anymore she's just as crazy
as this [ __ ] squirrel turd that we
got on the screen
Laura Logan that is again she's tweeted
at me I can pull it up
but I called Andy Noah Nazi I don't know
if you know Andy know is but he's a
goddamn Nazi too
he's a goddamn Internet troll he's the
one that that gets his gets his morons
all dressed up and they go pretend to be
antifa and he films [ __ ] and then he
puts it on the internet claim that it's
antifa he's a phony he's a fraud and so
is Laura Logan to be quite honest with
you
but there's nothing juicier there's
nothing juicier
then then these Q Anon supporters that
[ __ ] buy this [ __ ] Hook Line Sinker
this lady has there's no telling how
much money she sent an effort
of of the cute cause there's no [ __ ]
telling everything that you see behind
her is probably mortgaged
so that she can send more money
for Q Anon let's continue hey I'm
telling you it gets better and it gets
juicier and juicier all you can talk
about is the rape at the border you
can't talk about the real pandemic of
child trafficking none of you can and
it's in my e tree T Transmissions Q [ __ ]
you I'm telling you Q the minute I see
you I'm gonna punch you in the temple so
goddamn hard it's Gonna Knock You Out
well there you go she's gonna get in a
fist fight with q
how much money how much money would you
pay
[ __ ] much money would you pay to
watch this lady fight Q I'm dead serious
I'm dead serious
I'm not kidding how much money would you
I think we should put this [ __ ] on
Pay-per-view
Hells to the yeah
we could raise a [ __ ] ton of money
if we let this this wackadoo
box it out with whoever Q is of course
you know a lot of people think it's Mike
Flynn I don't know if she thinks it's
Mike Flynn
but you know it's a possibility
you remember you remember the um
the show celebrity it was a celebrity
boxing where celebrities would get in
the ring and they'd [ __ ] Hammer each
other's faces
for a couple minutes till one of them
[ __ ] fell in you remember that show
and maybe we should start doing
um um celebrity Nazi boxing you know
what I mean
I wouldn't mind watching
I don't know let's let's pick a couple
out what about Tempo and Nick Fuentes
who would pay good money to watch Nick
Fuentes
and Tim Poole box each other around for
I don't know 15-20 minutes
I pay some good money to watch that [ __ ]
for them to hammer each other in the
face I mean you know look it probably
wouldn't be much of a fight with those
two [ __ ] but I mean you know it'd be
fun to watch them slap each other around
a little bit
you're saying
I'm just saying I'm just
Wendy Wendy you're all over it
Wendy on on you David says paper queue
oh God damn see this is how you mock
these people
and that's the point here
the point of me showing you this and
directing you towards this content is to
absolutely mock the effort loving [ __ ]
out of these people
she is dead I don't know if you're aware
of this but this [ __ ] lunatic is dead
serious about everything she's saying
100 percent dead ass serious
this [ __ ] Wackadoo believes every
goddamn sound that's coming out of her
mouth
even if she has someone faking the orbs
she believes this [ __ ]
and you know she's trying to chase Q's
celebrity right because
in the grand scheme of things she wants
to be acknowledged
she doesn't want to be ignored right
I mean she wants to be Bannon to pay
attention to her extraterrestrial
Transmissions whatever the [ __ ] that
Jewish space laser [ __ ] is that she's
got going on she wants Laura Logan
she wants Q to acknowledge them
so she's she she's doing a lot of show
here to get them to pay attention that's
what the the pre-written sign that she
[ __ ] quits Q was about
because she absolutely knows inside the
cult
universe that when she quits the cult
they're gonna pay attention to her
quitting the cult especially if she has
any kind of following inside the cult
and I mean if it's just several dozen
people that listen and and absolutely
believe everything she says remember
that's very important
inside this universe is that even if she
just has a few dozen people
and those few dozen people have a few
other dozen people
of that sphere of influence that's the
most important part
that has that that has developed this
absolute [ __ ] National delusion of
this small percentage of people
they're [ __ ] they're just
they're enamored by this cult
and obviously she is too but she's
lashing out because she's seeking
attention well she's gonna get attention
just not the kind she was looking for
let's continue
it didn't have to be this way it never
had to be this way during the sinking of
Atlantis the archons did you see her
wiping orb off her face God damn I
didn't notice that the first time I
watched watch this watch this [ __ ]
lands right on her face there is someone
blowing styrofoam that's not a [ __ ]
filter that right here watch this [ __ ]
watch watch I'm not gonna play the sound
but watch this orb comes into the screen
right here right see it see it up there
see it up here right there see it right
up here see this piece of Styrofoam
right here maybe it's fake snow maybe
it's the [ __ ] you buy like Hobby Lobby
or some [ __ ] in a bag I don't know what
it is but someone is [ __ ] blowing it
off their hand look at this it's right
there like little white spot watch that
[ __ ] light spot it goes down
and it it right right right here it's
right there
and then watch
it hits her face and she wipes it off
her [ __ ] face
oh my God are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
oh God damn you have got to be [ __ ]
kidding me
I didn't notice this the first time that
I watched this I really didn't I'm just
now noticing it
Cindy says it's dust
I don't think it's dust Cindy honestly I
think someone they're making they're
they're doing it like it's intentional
that they're blowing it in front of the
camera
and
this love seat says it says Margie said
she needs a dustbuster
I don't know maybe she's in Canada and
she lives close to a gravel road or
something you know you live in the
country and you live close to a gravel
road you get a lot of [ __ ] dust maybe
it is dust I'm telling you though I'm
telling you it's intentional because she
calls them orbs and then she wipes one
right off her face
boom there it is uh oh not got on my
[ __ ] cheek and it probably tickled a
little bit you know what I mean you know
that a little piece of Styrofoam falls
on your face might tickle a little bit
you gotta wipe it off let's continue
let's continue with the craziness we're
almost done here I promise you got 30
seconds left in this video during the
sinking of Atlantis the archons took
over and that's how long it's taken you
to get back here and do anything at all
and even though you've gotten back here
and you sucked everybody into all of
this for this long nothing has happened
no arrests nothing we've got yet another
election stolen no no cue
whoosh she's talking about Atlantis and
all kinds and what in the [ __ ] and then
and then and then she goes on a tangent
about how there's no arrest
uh Margie she needs more than a Dust
Buster she needs some more brain cells
is what she needs listen
this is why you have to mock these
people at every turn right
we talk about comedy yesterday
um and how you shouldn't punch down in
comedy this isn't comedy I mean it's
funny it's hilarious meaning the parody
and satire that they're doing of
themselves is great that someone's
standing there blowing styrofoam into
this woman's face so she can talk about
orbs so she gets you know people to
believe that there's some kind of
magical Spirit or some [ __ ] about this
cult following of Q Anon and how she's
gonna leave because Q hasn't made a rest
yet this is so [ __ ] dumb what a
stupid what a stupid [ __ ] thing to
believe holy [ __ ] can you imagine can
you imagine waking up one day and
realizing that all this q a you believed
all this [ __ ] and then all this Q Anon
stuff is fake how [ __ ] dumb when you
feel well we need to make them feel that
way folks that's exactly right that's
why we mock them that's why we use
pieces of content like this to show that
you are some dumb stupid [ __ ]
it's ridiculous but what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do we have to we
have to [ __ ] undo this [ __ ]
we have to undo this nonsense
and the only way to undo it is to get
these people to see what they're doing
to themselves because they're doing it
to themselves
I mean yeah there's Bad actors right
come on it's to some degree to some
degree this lady knows that it's all
[ __ ] if she's willing to go to this
extent
to to go against q and this in the sex
trafficking ring and the
the
ET transmissions and someone's blowing
Styrofoam in her face so she can call it
[ __ ] so she can call it [ __ ] orbs
she knows it's all [ __ ] okay it's at
this point
she may have believed it but at this
point it's a [ __ ] act
let's let's continue let's watch the
rest of this crazy ass
[ __ ] box no
no matter what happens from here on in
I'm not coming back you blew it
next year will be seven years of doing
disclosure for you [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] all you orbs
get the [ __ ] out of my house I seriously
need to get out
I can't I can't help it I can't help but
laugh oh she's such a [ __ ] idiot oh
my god oh Jesus
how did they get down this [ __ ]
rabbit hole
whoosh I mean you know applaud the lady
that she's going against q but she's not
out of the woods yet I mean she's still
believing the nonsense or at least to
some degree pretending to believe the
nonsense right I mean she's she still
believes the garbage of the evidence
that there is that the election stolen
and that there's child sex trafficking
rings and pizza places and basements and
[ __ ] DC and she probably believes
Michael Jackson and JFK Jr line all
kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
foreign
to some degree at least at a bare
minimum that this [ __ ] still exists
but that's what I keep telling you about
affiliation right
the same way affiliation works for the
Republican party it's gonna work the
same way for the cult that's how Colt
works
it's the affiliation that they have
with the group with the cult with the
information
because really honestly if if you had
half a [ __ ] brain
you could you could go look up decent
information that would totally Smash Up
Your narrative lady I don't know what
her name is
we'll just call her and we'll call you
know man I'm trying to think I call
scary Lake scary lake so I don't want to
call her a scary Lake mama like
Mama Lake she's Carrie Lake's Mom I
don't know maybe that's a possibility
but Jesus [ __ ] Christ
it's a lot of crazy to pack in you know
20 30 minutes especially for a two
minute video but thank you for hatred
takes for posting that
because again this is a wedge you can
draw right because here's how here's how
affiliation and biased and third-party
confirmation works
here's how it works
if you show this to someone who believes
the crazy [ __ ] that this lady is talking
about in this video
and you show that to someone they may
just crack their brain just enough to go
you know what she's right
Q didn't listen to the Extraterrestrial
transmission missions Q didn't Q didn't
use the disclosure
and it's been six years and there's
still no arrest
maybe it cracks their brain just enough
just enough for them the question the
cult
right maybe not leave the ideas that the
cult presents but to question the cult
and that's the off-ramp that we need
that's the long road of recovery from
this [ __ ] disease that is spread
around our country in the minds of these
[ __ ] lunatics
we need mental health care we need it
fast that's the story here okay let's go
to the uh
let's go to the who wants to who wants
to talk about Tulsi gambard and George
Santos let's see wait a second wait a
second wait a second Ted Cruz is
trending for buffalo
what the [ __ ] did he do or say
Ted Cruz is trending for Buffalo
you know there's a big huge snowstorm
several people have died unfortunately
um because we're just not prepared for
these types of storms that are caused a
climate change in this country we're
just not prepared for it I mean Jesus
Christ you get six eight feet of snow in
one area and they're not used to that
amount of snow in that short amount of
time God damn it's going to be tough
so several people have died as a result
of this storm in Buffalo
um but Ted Cruz is trending with Buffalo
so I I'm only here to imagine that he
sends his tots and pears
to people in Buffalo
uh let's see see if I can find it
um on what oh Jesus Christ oh God damn
whoosh
so apparently Ted Cruz is slammed Joe
Biden for going to Saint Croix on
vacation
um because the Buffaloes has a snowstorm
but Ted Cruz fails to remember when
Texas froze
he went to Cancun of course and you and
you people think you people think George
Santos is the problem what the [ __ ] he's
he's just the result of the symptoms
folks just like Ted Cruz is
you kidding me
if listen listen to me for a second
if the last lady we watched
who disavowed Q because Q wasn't
listening to her extraterrestrial
Transmissions her Jewish space lasers
and her disclosures oh Jesus
do you do you actually think that she's
gonna not believe Ted Cruz when he says
this type of [ __ ] when he says the lies
do you think she's not gonna believe
George Santos come on
come on oh oh and MJ says uh
I I should show uh the Greta thundberg
tweet yeah I'm gonna get to that I think
I think I'm gonna get to that date MJ
thank you for reminding me we have the
best mods in the world give them all
love in the chat there thank you MJ for
reminding me
Ted Cruz [ __ ] Ted Cruz and anyone who
looks like Ted Cruz [ __ ] them okay
oh well here Greta's trending at number
one
um apparently with Andrew Tate I think
that's the uh the tweet
that um MJ's referring to
so let's go see what's in this what's in
there what's in this thread
what's in this tread uh oh okay here we
go so this is the um
this
here's the Tweet by Andrew Tate uh you
know Andrew Tate was banned from Twitter
until
um uh Elmo took I mean Elon Musk and
bought
um Twitter for 44 billion dollars is in
and burning Burning It To The Ground all
the while burning Tesla too God damn
Elon it's amazing that you could lose so
much wealth in two companies in such a
little amount of time you are a genius
okay so um Andrew Tate here if you guys
watch videos of this pile of [ __ ] holy I
could do six hours
on this stupid [ __ ]
I I here's the thing
Andrew Tate if you're listening it is it
is advisable it is advisable that you
never get within spitting distance of me
my friend you [ __ ] phony what a
goddamn punk ass [ __ ] this Andrew Tate
is I don't know if you listen to him
talk about women and [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
pile of garbage
and that there's another person I'd I'd
like to watch
someone getting a boxing ring with him
again Andrew really honestly you and
your stupid [ __ ] cigars and your bare
ass chest just man you do not
do not get in a room me but he tweets at
Greta thundberg when I don't know if you
know but granted Thunderbird is an
underage girl which is right on brand
for Andrew Tate but he says hello Greta
I have 33 cars what the [ __ ] does that
mean what in the actual [ __ ] he has 33
cars
oh well
good for you what the [ __ ] his bulgatty
two Ferraris on and on he goes with the
[ __ ] stupid lies
he rents these cars to take pictures
with him folks that's what he does he
rents the cars so he can take pictures
with him
it's not that complicated oh [ __ ]
this is just to start yeah I'm sure it's
just the start to your 33 cars okay
33 Matchbox maybe but he says Please
provide your email so I can send a
complete list to my car collection in
their respective enormous emissions
so he's trying to he's trying to get at
um Greta Thunder a teenage girl he's won
her email address Jesus Christ
look dude
if you're if you're gonna you know do
this to a teenage girl he might maybe I
don't know maybe do it in the open but
he's asking for email here
so he can send a complete list
of his car collection
post it in a thread you dumb
[ __ ] the reason why he doesn't
post this in a thread is because he's a
lion sank as [ __ ]
he literally this is a picture of this
stupid [ __ ]
he probably rented these clothes even he
probably doesn't even own the clothes he
rented the clothes rented the car drove
it to the gas station stuck the pump in
to make it look like he's filling that
[ __ ] up he's only putting enough
[ __ ] fuel in it so he can get it back
to the rental place
in between his photo shoots right this
is all [ __ ] he didn't own these cars
just like we showed this guy and Gabe
had a picture of him on a [ __ ]
airplane
said he was going to the Twitter
headquarters
to thank Elon Musk personally that
[ __ ] picture was taken of him months
before and he posted it other places
he's a [ __ ] fraud and a phony it's
all [ __ ]
this nonsense
just I mean good God you believe
anything these [ __ ] these these
snowflake
trumped up manga men are saying
now here's the thing
um
[Laughter]
MJ wants me to show the Greta um tweet I
have not read this until just
oh my God
Greta please please come on the show and
explain
why you chose this email
you're gonna [ __ ] love this thank you
MJ everyone's begging me to show it I'm
obviously I'm holding off showing it
just to hold you in suspense here but
holy [ __ ] this has to be if this doesn't
win tweet of the year
um at least in the top ten
so Greta thunderberg quote tweets him
and says yes please do enlighten me
email me
[Music]
at small dick energy at get a life oh
God
laughs
oh my God
oh [ __ ] sick burn Greta seriously if
you need some place to um
explain why you have this email
um this would be the perfect spot holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that is [ __ ] hilarious
oh my god oh [ __ ]
that cannot make me more happy do I
follow Greta because
um if not no I gotta follow him now
um of course Greta has a blue check
um because she's
um a Legacy account she's notable right
um I want to see Andrew Tate has a blue
check let's see what
oh
Andrew Tate now look here
look here look at this cuck
look at this Elon cuck look at this guy
here we go I'll show it
oh Andrew Tate has to pay for his blue
check
and Greta doesn't hmm
blue checks really are if you're buying
them
to simp for Elon which Andrew Tate most
certainly is that's why Elon gave him
back his account so he could get eight
bucks a month from Andrew
you're a cuck
you're a [ __ ] little punk ass [ __ ]
and you sent for Elon
put a [ __ ] shirt on quit smoking so
many cigars and carrying around the same
bottle of cognac
and quit renting cars and claiming that
you own them you've you [ __ ] dip [ __ ]
oh my god oh why why do people why do
people
follow these [ __ ] idiots on the
internet
the F he's got three point three million
violence which probably 70 percent of
them are fake but even then he's got a
couple hundred thousand people there
oh Jesus Christ
I'm telling you what you want to see how
stupid this guy is
let's not stop
um
speaking of Andrew Tate I haven't done a
lot of Andrew take content I haven't
I did do some content with Walter
Masterson one time on his live stream he
live streams and he likes to troll q and
honors on his live stream and
um we were talking about Andrew Tate and
he has this thing called I don't know
some kind of University [ __ ] it's like
Hustler University or some stupid [ __ ]
where he sells a membership to tell men
how to beat more manly like him you know
rent really expensive cars to pretend
like you own them make sure you sit
around with your shirt off rent a plane
take a lot of footage from the plane and
a lot of pictures on the plane from
different angles and different outfits
that you rent so that way you can claim
you were on the plane more than once uh
you know [ __ ] like that manly [ __ ] like
that
but uh this dumb [ __ ] uh some of
the [ __ ] he says here's here's here's a
here's a here's a sampling of it it says
I don't know what show this is
this is how dumb this [ __ ] is
now he posted this this is him posting
this
he posted this [ __ ] video okay I I
didn't post a [ __ ] video no one else
but he posted this [ __ ] watch this [ __ ]
you know one of the most interesting
lessons from the Matrix movies because I
talk about the Matrix a lot there's all
the obvious ones everyone talks about
but in the second Matrix movie when he
gets to the end and he speaks to the guy
in the white suit I don't know if you
guys are talking to know what I'm
talking about and the guy in the white
suit is very very clear and punctual and
compenduous English very interesting I
like the way he talks because he uses
very very
he thinks the Matrix is real is that
what you're getting from this so far I
mean we're [ __ ] 18 seconds into this
and Andrew Tate thinks the movie Matrix
Is Real at this point let's continue
Advanced language and he's explaining
that Neo you're not special you think
you're going to destroy the Matrix but
you're not the reason you exist is we
allow anomalies and the reason we allow
people do you get the sense that this
guy got his ass kicked every day when he
was in high school I mean just got his
[ __ ] ass beat stuffed in a locker got
got pushed I'm not saying that it was a
good thing
kids shouldn't get bullied but this guy
got bullied like a [ __ ] I mean
got his ass kicked got made fun of
I mean they probably don't tell him how
many swirlies when this guy actually had
hair and he didn't have the receding
hairline where he's got to shave his
head there's no telling how many
swirlies this guy get
I'm just saying how I mean there his mom
probably had to buy just dozens of
packages of underwear every single month
to keep up with the wedgies that this
guy was getting
100 percent
this guy got [ __ ] with a lot
and they beat it broken it [ __ ] broke
him right
holy [ __ ] let's let's keep going about
his
great mind on how the Matrix is real I
don't know need to exist is because if
if everyone's stuck inside the Matrix
saw no hope whatsoever and saw that
nobody could ever escape the matrix
would collapse if the Matrix didn't
allow anybody to become rich and
successful ever then the Matrix will
collapse you have to believe you know
what if I do what I'm supposed to do
long enough I might be able to end up
like that guy so that's why they allow
the anomalies the point I'm trying to
make is the Matrix is difficult and it's
crushing and and soul destroying as it
is they have deliberately left gaps for
the people who are prepared to to escape
to escape they leave home he thinks that
[ __ ] is real right am I [ __ ] off my
rocker here
foreign
whoosh this game holy [ __ ]
oh Andrew get a [ __ ] life man and
stop stop
someone pointed out the in
um Great Adventure excuse Greta
thundberg maybe 20. I don't know
I have no idea how old she is but I mean
the problem is is with the pandemic I
don't know I don't know how old she is I
have no idea I don't know I don't know
it just seems kind of weird that he
would be asking for her email but her
response
is epic iconic and beautiful thank you
Greta for your response and thank you MJ
for reminding me of that it's trending
number one
training number one but this guy is a
[ __ ] box just go go watch some of this
[ __ ] that this guy puts out
it's
it's mind-bending how bone-handed it is
it really is okay um we got to go to the
Tulsi stuff because we're getting into
the second half of the second hour here
um we're gonna get to the top of the
hour before I get to some of this
footage of Tulsi and I want to show you
the [ __ ] piece of footage and uh um I
think it was Robin one of our great
moderators Robin pointed it out to me in
a DM this morning
um about
the clip where Tulsi gabbard is talking
about how George Santos is going to go
to the floor of the house and no one's
gonna believe him I wonder where she got
that [ __ ] from
I said that yesterday
I said that [ __ ] yesterday and I said we
should be cheering that this
[ __ ] goes to the floor of the
house and spews
pews
Republican lies that's what we want
that's what we want he's a no liar they
know he's a liar they're calling him a
liar we want him to go to the floor of
the house and repeat their lies that's
what we want we have to politicize the
[ __ ] out of it
Scott says Today's Show is flying by
I don't know it might be because it's
just me here is that why I don't know
I mean
seems like it it might be the crazy lady
that we were watching that was a lot of
fun that was a lot of fun and Barbara
says she's 19. so she oh that's not
that's not the one I want
she's 19.
so she is a teenager
she's not Henry she's a teenager yeah I
missed the mark a little bit coretta's
been around for a while the [ __ ] time
flies by man
Jesus Christ my I got a kid that's damn
near 18.
it's crazy [ __ ]
it's not something I'd like to admit but
my son is about to graduate high school
oh [ __ ]
um
so yeah okay so we're in and Kim wants
to go to Tulsi Tulsi
Tulsi gambered and let's see
let's see if I can find the clip and
acen had a thread I believe was it
Easton or was it Aaron that had the
thread maybe it's Aaron that has a
thread yeah
a lot of people got threads
I thought that was a threat what the
[ __ ]
um
I'm gonna find it here I promise
just just don't yeah it's Aaron that has
the thread from last night of Tucker
Carlson's show you know Aaron was banned
um Elon shut him off because Elon got
mad at him as Aaron posted something
that Elon didn't like
but he's got his account back I said he
would get his account back and I said
it's not that much of a travesty that
Aaron loses his account right everyone
thought it was a crime against
journalism that's not how the free press
works Aaron is free to report but he
doesn't he's not free to have an account
on Twitter but here is the lead up
to the and Aaron Aaron does a lot of
good work go follow Aaron
you should put him on notifications
frankly
um because I show a lot of his Clips so
I want to thank Aaron for doing the hard
work of finding these clips but this
content is not Aaron's content
Aaron's just reporting it he's showing
it to you just like I show you when he
shows you so he shows it and then I go
through his stuff and I'm like hey this
is the important one that we need to
politicize right Aaron's just trying to
disclose this stuff he's just trying to
make sure this is out in the world that
people know what these [ __ ] [ __ ]
boxes are saying that's the most
important thing
here and then what I do is I go through
and I figure out what part we can
politicize and how we politicize it that
way we can form a national narrative and
messaging to make sure we save our
democracy so we're all on the same team
here
but we also have to realize that YouTube
can shut me off anytime they want it's
their platform
and Twitter can turn Aaron off anytime
he wants that's why it's important for
you to follow
people like us to make sure you keep in
touch if we lose one platform we may be
on another
so it's important so go follow Aaron on
Twitter and anywhere else that you you
can find him I think he has a sub stack
too anyways
anyways
yeah back to the task at hand here uh
Tulsi gabbard in the lead up the
thumbnail here the the screenshot is who
is George Santos so Tulsi is gonna dive
into this and you notice this is on
Tucker Carlson's White Privilege tonight
right
and she did that the Chiron says
Straight Ahead Congressman elect
explains all to Tulsi
this is all in an effort to discredit
George Santos from the right by the way
that's what all this [ __ ] is
um every single one of these clips and
the entire interview
is so that the right wing can claim that
they discredited to George Santos when
they're ready to toss him aside
because they will toss him aside folks
McCarthy needs him to get to 218.
they really need him on the floor and
they need him to help get their [ __ ]
committees going right they're going to
need as many votes as they need
as they can get George Santos is one of
them
but they're setting George Santos up for
him to be 86th when they need 86. he may
not know that but that's what they're
doing here
because they're gonna set it up to where
they're like oh we never liked we never
we never liked you with Santos that Tony
Michaels he makes this sound like every
one of us is George Santos but we never
we never lacked him he would we always
knew he was a fraud remember when toasty
gabbard interviewed him on Tucker
Carlson's a white privilege tonight you
remember that
that's what they're gonna say
but again we have to create the
narrative now right now in the moment we
can't wait
we have to do it now that's why we have
to make sure that this [ __ ] gets
on the floor of the house and says the
old
Republican lies every last one of them
about Hunter Biden about inflation about
gas prices about Ukraine about Russia
every [ __ ] single one and speaking of
Russia
I'm getting a sense
and we're going to find out that this
gang took Russia money and that is how
the Republican party is gonna 86 him
okay after they've done what they need
to do with him
but don't think we can't use George
Santos as well but I'm telling you
they're trying I said yesterday our
narrative is gonna be that he's a liar
he's a [ __ ] liar and he went on the
house the floor of the House of
Representatives and he told every single
Republican line because he's okay with
lying
and all of a sudden in the same night
here's Tulsi gabbard on Tucker Carlson's
White Privilege tonight
making sure
that my narrative is not being told
it's happening folks they're terrified
not of me I mean they are but of you
they're terrified of you listening to me
and then go spreading the messaging
you're spreading the narrative they're
[ __ ] terrified of it
so much so that they're willing to
produce an entire Fox News segment
to try to stop that near listen to this
um the reality is is that I remain
committed to doing everything I set
forward in my campaign I'm not a fraud
I'm not a fake I I didn't materialize
from thin air
oh he's not a fraud he's not a fake yeah
you know wow
[ __ ] has to go on Fox News and
say the words I'm not a fraud I'm not a
fake
the irony in that at all okay let's go
to the next one there's a several Clips
here but the one that I want to point
out about
I think that one of Tucker Carlson's
producers is watching the show someone's
watching no way did I say that yesterday
and they didn't [ __ ] get this [ __ ]
um here's uh here's the quote from this
clip
um where tulsi's knocking him and a lot
of people were like oh I agree with
Tulsi here but listen to what when I
tell you this the reason why you agree
with Tulsi is because she's trying to
control the narrative they're trying to
reverse the narrative when you see that
when you see that you're agreeing with
someone like Tulsi gabbard a Russian
propagandist
um on the Russian propaganda show Tucker
Carlson White Privilege tonight when you
see that know that they're trying to
sway the messaging against us and it's
and our messaging is working when you
see that that's what that means let's
listen
the thing is Congressman elect uh
integrity means yes carrying yourself
with honor but it means it means telling
the truth being a person of integrity
and if I were one of those in New York's
Third District right now now that the
election is over and I'm finding out
okay again I got to point out that Tulsi
yarbert is a horrible host she's
horrible at Broadcasting
it would be like if I sat here and
talked like this the entire time and
asked my guests the most boring question
and made the Civilized talking analogies
and made it's [ __ ] boring she's
boring as [ __ ] [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] did they have Tulsi gabbard
other than she's completely in the camp
of Putin and Russia
and she's on Russian television
basically I mean that's what this is
Tucker Carlson's White Privilege tonight
is Russian TV like literally they play
the majority of it they're gonna play
this interview in Russia probably
would be my guess they're gonna do
commentary on this interview that Tulsi
gabbard the the Russian [ __ ]
propagandist is doing with George Santos
the bottom paid for Russian congressman
from New York's third
I did I mean just think about it it's
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing
that that on Dr Carlson's Russian TV
content machine
that these two
Tulsi gambard who is completely in the
camp for Putin
is [ __ ] interviewing and calling the
person who took Russian money
to make sure that they won the Congress
this the seat in Congress in New York's
third
at all cost why about anything and
everything because he's a republican
that he was running on the Republican
ticket of course he would lie about
anything to get the seat and of course
he would take Russian money
to get the seat
it's mind-blowing that Tulsi gabbard and
this person appears on a show
that is likely
to get Russian TV actual Russian TV
commentary
of this interview it is [ __ ]
mind-blowing
that's why this is so [ __ ] important
and I know it seems crazy that the
possibility
that I said yesterday we want this
[ __ ] to go to the floor of the
house to lie and then all of a sudden
here are two [ __ ] Russian assets on
what is Russian TV in America
talking about the same theory that I
said yesterday that we're going to use
against them
but here we are
let's continue all of these lies that
you've told not just one little lie or
one little embellishment these are
blatant lies my question is do you have
no shame do you have no shame in the
people who are now you are asking to
trust you to go and be their voice for
them their families and their kids in
Washington no irony whatsoever in Tulsi
gabbard who is a former congressperson
who has been on this show as a guest in
the other seat lying her [ __ ] ass off
asking a guest as the guest host Jesus
[ __ ] Christ it doesn't end it doesn't
end should I show his response I you
know let's listen I mean I don't know if
we need to hear much of his response on
this but let's listen
Tulsi I can say the same thing about the
Democrats and and the party look at Joe
Biden Joe Biden's been lying to the
American people for 40 years he's the
president of the United States Democrats
resoundly support him do they have no
shame because look this is made this
very this is not this is not about
Democratic uh-oh uh-oh uh oh the reason
why Tulsi gabbard is not happy about him
saying that is because again I told you
yesterday it's the old Republican
[ __ ] lie it's the [ __ ] lie and
he's telling it she's saying right on
the [ __ ] show you are a fraud you're
a phony it's shameful what you're doing
by lying to the constituents in New
York's third
and then he repeats the old Republican
lies the defense
folks this is what we want this is
exactly what we want I know it doesn't
seem like it I know it doesn't feel like
it you're like Jesus Christ Tony really
this is what we want this is what we
want
um here is here's a here's another clip
of it and we're going to play several of
these we got uh we got about 12 minutes
left in the show so we're gonna play
several of these and let's listen to
this Democratic party though this is
about your relationship frankly with the
people who've entrusted you to go and
and what she's saying there what she's
saying there's keep our propaganda out
of your mouth that's what she's saying
she's saying do not use our propaganda
and our way to deflect do not use our
projection do not use our deflection
tactics
because if you use our propaganda and
you you you
co-opt our messaging it's it's going to
have less an effect when we say it
because you're saying it that's what I
said yesterday that's what I said
yesterday
and George Santos is a [ __ ] gift from
the Republican party they let him be
their nominee folks
the Republican party did not have they
could have destroyed this [ __ ]
but they didn't
and they know that he just they just
need to get him to vote for Kevin
McCarthy or just get him to vote for
whatever [ __ ] Republicans gonna be
speaker because they can't put a vote
together
um here is here it is here's the clip so
here's the follow-up here
this is the clip I I think
I want to get proper credit was it Robin
that sent this to me mods in the um
she sent this
um pointed this out to me when I seen it
someone like ooh this made me this made
me feel good
the propaganda start listening
they're listening
they're probably in the chat right now
but here is the let me make this bigger
boom let's make this full screen here
this is worth it for this
so this is where Tulsi gabbard
is trying is trying to turn what I said
yesterday is going to be our greatest
messaging for the next it probably we'll
get three for maybe five months off
George Santos in our messaging okay or
it's not gonna last forever like we're
not I mean we'll be able to go back to
it and we'll be able to refer to it but
we can't we're not going to be able to
use him for a messaging forever right
but we got to do what we can do to push
it forward
keep going keep going keep going the
national narrative but the Republicans
are [ __ ] frauds and George Santos is
a gift from the Republican Party
here it is
this is this is the clip that makes me
think
that someone's watching our show
and they're they're paying attention to
what you're doing
like like here's the thing
yeah sometimes we get a thousand two
thousand people watching this at any
given time live but it gets tens of
thousands of views every single day
and they're not exactly paying attention
exactly what I'm saying and exactly what
I'm doing but they're paying attention
to you
we've had to get and you know this we
have the greatest moderators in the
world we've had to get more moderators I
even had I've even had to slow down the
chat
you know what that means they're
terrified of your engagement that's what
they're terrified of
they're they're terrified of your
engagement in democracy
that's what you do when you come here
every single day
is your your engaging in a national
narrative you're engaging in National
messaging
for pro-democracy stance
because they want to kill democracy that
is their goal
the authoritarian will authoritarianism
will not live
when democracy is still standing
they have to kill democracy to get to
where they want to be which is
authoritarianism
okay
so they're paying attention to you
uh Margie says slow Chad is our friend
but but the reason why I had to slow
down the chat is because you guys are
like ding ding ding ding ding
right
you're like the Democracy pinball
machine
and that that is what they pay attention
to
I mean I could sit here and talk all day
long
and if a few thousand people watch me
great but if no one engages
if they don't notice that you guys are
engaging in the chat and then you go out
and you start spreading around this
messaging right that you start spreading
it around it starts growing
they wouldn't they wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but they're paying attention to you
paying attention to you
Sage says come on Tony play the clip hey
I gotta let you hang here a little bit
right I gotta let I gotta make you wanna
watch this thing all right so here is
Tulsi gabbard here's Tulsi gabbard
trying to undo what I told you yesterday
and you guys must have went out and
[ __ ] started commenting everywhere
that's what happened it ain't it may not
be because they're listening to me
directly
but they're definitely paying attention
to you let's watch
the results that people are looking for
are called into question when you tell
blatant lies not embellishments and this
is this is I think one of the biggest
concerns Congressman elect is that you
don't really seem to be taking this
seriously you've apologized you said
you've made mistakes but you've outright
lie a lie is not an embellishment on a
resume you said you worked at Goldman
Sachs and Citigroup but they've said
we've got no record of this guy working
for us you've said you've gone to and
graduated from these universities but
they've said well we've got no record of
that these are blatant lies and it calls
into question how your constituents and
the American people can believe anything
that you may say when you are standing
on the floor of the House of
Representatives supposedly fighting for
them that's
and there you have it
there you have it
I said yesterday the number one reason
why we want George Santos to remain a
congressperson is so he goes to the
floor of the house and speaks into a
microphone on official record and tells
old worn out Republican lies the America
First Nazi party will need him to tell
lies but we need him to tell those lies
into a microphone as well because we
have to politicize it and Tulsi gabbard
and Tucker Carlson's White Privilege
tonight is all over it they know that's
what we're gonna do because I said it
yesterday and you guys went out and you
[ __ ] started talking about it on the
internet and they noticed
they noticed
and then they noticed quickly
that's the most important thing we have
we have to keep them on their heels
we have to and there's OB there's an
obvious there's an obvious effort
on the right to make sure that George
Santos
is not legitimized
in their movement
because if he is legitimizing their
movement they own every single one of
his lives including the ones they want
to tell
got it that is the most important thing
here now I want to point out something
else
with this clip
that I noticed
and this goes back to him receiving
Russian money because let me tell you
something a lot of money will change a
person
especially if it's given money and
there's expectation for that given money
it'll change a person's entire
personality
almost overnight
and you notice when Tulsi gabbard is is
flinging these accusations at him
basically calling it well not basically
she called him a total [ __ ] liar
about him being at Goldman Sachs and
other organizations
which they said they have no idea who
this [ __ ] is
he's not phased by it one bit
watch his facial expression
while she's flinging this
he's not phased one bit folks you want
to know what a bunch of [ __ ] money
with a bunch of expectations from people
who will Who will [ __ ] get rid of you
do you want to know what it'll do to a
personality
it'll do this [ __ ]
that's what that is
so believe it or not believe me or not I
don't give a [ __ ]
I'm telling you George Santos is a gift
from the American first Nazi party to
pro-democracy Coalition a gift
they know it and they know it because
yesterday I said it and then you went
out and you [ __ ] started spreading
the messaging and that's how it works
folks
this is a prime example of how this
works and how it's supposed to work
this is how they've done it for years
with talk radio
how do you think how do you think
rushman law became so powerful inside
the Republican Party
he was able to spread whatever message
he could and they would go out and
disseminate the lies well you can
disseminate the truth that's what you
can do we do not have to do it with lies
we can do it with the truth
and we can defend our democracy with
messaging and narrative
we can do it together
so come every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours just like we
did today listen to that messaging that
narrative and go spread it around
spread it around like it's herpes
because they're listening
they're paying attention they're losing
the grip on the national narrative it's
been a lot of work with 2020 and 2022
midterms now we have 2024 right ahead of
us and we have to keep it up we can not
stop
our democracy depends on you it depends
on me depends on all of us
being on the same page the same there
with the same messaging we must fight
for it trust me it's worth it everybody
go subscribe to the YouTube channel if
you're here subscribe right now or if
you're on another platform go subscribe
to the YouTube channel don't forget to
watch us again every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch we simulcast from the mind to
touch Facebook page but also follow us
on Facebook and go FD Tony Michaels and
really you can go to Just you can just
go to thetonymichaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com you can find all the
social media places you can find you can
go download every single episode Apple
Spotify Google they're all there all the
links are there on the Tony michaels.com
you can even go get your [ __ ] them hand
Everyone likes the [ __ ] hands who
doesn't who doesn't want a bug a man I
think a red black blue there's pink
and also you can also go to the merch
store and get
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty sweatshirt
it's warming up but boy it's cold you
might want to have this one it's really
warm too it's super warm the zip up
Hoodie is freaking I gotta take it off
it's so warm sometimes
so go to d20michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com
it's been great it's been a great show
it went by fast I don't know who said
that earlier but it's went by really
fast today and hopefully it changes go
give him some love on Twitter
we'll follow him on Twitter and I am
Gabe Sanchez go tell him to feel better
and he's still a little under the
weather so hopefully he'll be able to
join us tomorrow
and a regular time
regular place until then surf some
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon